la famille un des sujets préférés de
jean paul ii le pape est venu les
écouter tous ces couples et ses enfants
réunis à sainte anne d'auray
ils ont parlé et ils ont raconté le
chômage l'exclusion et le divorce
mon mari m'a annoncé qu'il me quittait
pour partir vivre à l'étranger mais
laissant seul avec les enfants ce fut
une longue descente aux enfers
c'est à cette femme comme à tous les
couples séparés et particulièrement les
divorcés remariés qui n'ont plus droit
aux sacrements que le pape s'est d'abord
adressé à aussi les sushis dhr qui s'en
séparait il vaut cher et divorce elle
est mariée est membre la position n'est
pas nouvelle mais aujourd'hui devant
toutes ces familles réunies jean paul ii
exprime un changement d'attitude de
l'église catholique plus de
compréhension d'accueil et de chaleur
pour les couples divorcés son avortement
par contre toujours le même message
dowd a dreamer désagréger a droit à
l'existence la vie donnèrent
n'appartient plus à celle qu'il en
prenne est toujours la même fermeté sur
le principe du droit à la vie
une fermeté qui assure aux papous
franc succès auprès de ses fidèles